welcome to the man of recaps this is
westworld season three remember in
season two dolores led the robot
uprising to free the hosts of westworld
from human control in the end dolores
put her mind in a robot body of delos
board member charlotte tail and was able
to escape to the mainland now she's
rebuilt her own body and is
theoretically continuing her plans for a
worldwide robot uprising so this season
we're not in westworld anymore this
story takes place in the real near
future world for a country bumpkin
dolores adapts real quick to that big
city life in this world where
everything's computerized her being a
robot basically gives her superpowers
and since she figures out that money is
basically another superpower so she gets
a bunch of that real quick dolores plan
centers around this young tech guy in
fact she's already dating him his
company insight has developed an
advanced artificial intelligence
rehoboam whose predictive algorithms
basically control a lot of the world and
to see how it affects your average human
we meet a new main character this season
it's aaron paul as caleb caleb has a
sort of lonely sad life he's working a
dead-end job as a construction worker he
goes to apply for better ones but the
rehoboam algorithm says he's not good
enough he never gets them so knights who
works a side hustle with the rico crime
app yes it's basically uber for crime
he's playing real life gta so dolores is
doing some corporate espionage but
pretty soon the head of security catches
her but oh she wanted to be caught goes
into beast mode takes all these guys out
turns out she's built a robot copy of
the security head and replaces him with
her host friend but it turns into a big
shootout where dolores gets to use her
gunslinging skill but caleb was actually
called in on this job but realized
something was wrong and now he sees an
injured dolores and saves her just like
william did back in the park in season
one she's like hey man you're cool i
could use your help she shows him that
his life is even more controlled than he
thought to rehoboam's algorithms become
a self-fulfilling prophecy and he's
predicted to kill himself right here in
about 10 years so dolores becomes
caleb's sexy leather-clad morpheus it's
time to free your mind neo and he's like
hell yeah i'm in another part of
delores's plan is with robot charlotte
hale originally dolores put her own mind
in there but we don't know who's inside
anymore dolores smuggled out a couple of
the pearls so it could be anyone now
delos is reeling from the whole robot
uprising thing but robo charlotte's
trying to buy the rest of the board out
and take the company private that way
she and dolores will have full control
of westworld and building new hosts but
there's a problem she needs the votes of
an absent board member yes it's william
the man in black he is not doing well at
the moment remember last season he
killed his real-life daughter because he
thought she was a host and now he's
fully descended into madness so
charlotte's gotta pay him a visit you'll
pull yourself together i need your votes
now it's time to check in on bernard who
has ditched the nerdy programmer look
for a sexy lumberjack look dolores
rebuilt him out here in the main world
even though they're theoretically
opposed dolores wanted to conquer
humanity while bernard is more of a
pacifist wanted them to all live in
peace so bernard is running diagnostics
on himself but he needs better tech so
he takes a ship back to westworld here
he finds the head of park security
ashley stubbs who turns out is a host
himself everyone who predicted that you
were right they go through the office of
another park we haven't seen yet
medieval world yeah looks awesome and
while bernard's doing his thing stubs
grabs an axe to get into character so
now bernard remembers some of delores
plan he and stubs going on a bro road
trip to stop her but now it's time to
check in on maeve who's wearing
old-timey clothing where is she she's
been transferred to yet another park
it's world war ii world i did not see
that coming she's reunited with an old
friend yes it's hector no longer the
sexy western bandit the sexy italian
resistance fighter they go on a fun spy
adventure but during their escape it's
apparent hector doesn't remember maeve
he's just playing out his loop and so
maeve escapes for real by shooting
herself to wake up backstage where she's
reunited with her human friend lee
sizemore who went out in a hail of
gunfire to protect her last season but
apparently he survived remember last
season maeve sacrificed herself so her
daughter and the other hosts could live
in the virtual paradise world the
sublime which dolores later beamed off
into the cloud so he takes her down
there like put in the coordinates then
you can go join your daughter but she's
like what i don't know he's like it's
okay my love you can trust me but she's
like yo that's not the relationship we
had and she realizes this isn't the real
lee sizemore in fact this isn't the real
world she's in a virtual simulation so
she hatches a plan to cause a bunch of
chaos to overload the system and crash
it now she's able to access the outside
world she hacks a robot grabs her brain
and busts on out of there but in the end
she doesn't quite make it now she wakes
up in a real body and meets her host the
main antagonist this season the french
guy sorak turns out he is the real owner
of rehoboam the young guy's just a
figurehead he recruits maeve to fight on
his team against dolores and he controls
this body so he's not really asking
apparently paris was nuked when he was a
kid so he designed rehoboam to control
humanity and protect it from itself but
his predictive models of human behavior
aren't perfect turns out the westworld
files are better dolores sent those off
with the sublime so he's like get the
location then i'll get those files then
you can go be with your daughter so now
it's fancy party time dolores and caleb
going to kidnap this guy bernard and
stubs going there too to save him for
robot security guy's there to stop him
it's like oh which host are you is that
you in there teddy meanwhile maeve
breaks into dolores yakuza headquarters
where she's able to hack all these guys
auto-amine guns and take them out easily
the new yakuza leader is also a host on
dolores team it's like oh who are you is
that you in there teddy meanwhile robot
charlie tail is playing william she
tells him she's a host so that he
attacks her and rants about a robot
uprising so she can have him committed
and get his votes that way and so
simultaneously we learn the identity of
all three of these hosts and turns out
they are all dolores yes she just copied
herself in all the bodies if you want
something done right do it yourself so
maeve and dolores have katana fight
round one this one dolores wins and
dolores wins on all fronts she
successfully got this guy he fights back
though with the only weapon he has on
him a party drug called genre which
makes your life feel like a movie so
caleb's tripping in black and white but
when they get into a car chase he shifts
genres she gives them a big gun hey man
you're in an action movie now in the end
dolores wins uses this guy's access to
leak all of rehoboam's data on people to
everyone in the world and people aren't
happy to see their entire lives are
decided for them so it's the opposite of
westworld as dolores incites the human
revolution against their computer
overlords but dolores doesn't win on the
corporate front sirock buys up delos in
a hostile takeover and soon he figures
out that charlottetale is the robot
imposter see she's got a family that
robo charlotte's become very attached to
but real charlotte was never that good a
mom but charlotte escapes with some help
from another robot friend the massive
new security droid
meanwhile maeve is chilling in virtual
world as she's waiting for her body to
be rebuilt but now that sorak owns delos
she's able to recruit her some friends
and maeve is reunited with the real
hector but on her way out charlor has
sabotaged maeve by crushing hector's
unit killing him for real so when maeve
wakes up she's real mad now delores just
made this personal and soon we get to
see who else maybe recruited yes it's
her friend clementine and the girl from
samurai world so watch out for them but
as for charlotte hale she's not the same
dolores anymore she's grown to be her
own person and wants to just run away
from all this with her family
unfortunately sir rock boom blows up her
car killing her family leaving her
burned like anakin and now she's real
mad ready to go full darth vader dolores
prime is on an adventure with caleb this
isn't westworld it's the real west she
finally comes clean to him about being a
robot he's like are you trying to
destroy humanity but she's like no i'm
trying to free all of us they find
sorok's secret compound with the
rehoboam prototype that he built with
his brother but there's a problem with
their plan to create a perfect
controlled world too many people are
outliers you just can't predict infects
rock's brother is one of them and so
soraka kidnapped these people tried to
mess with their minds to fix them and
for the ones that didn't work he's got
them frozen here in cryosleep but now
caleb learns he's been here before he is
one of sarah's outliers that's had his
memory messed with yeah we know all
about caleb's best friend francis they
were in the military together but he
died tragically but now caleb remembers
francis didn't die on duty they both
made it home rehoboam pushed them into
doing crime jobs specifically taking out
other outliers until eventually the
system told them to take out each other
how much they offer you man enough and
oh caleb had to kill his best friend so
now caleb's madder than ever ready to
burn this whole thing to the ground but
first maeve shows up in its katana fight
round two this time though she brought a
drone for backup and is gonna win but
dolores hits the emp and knocks them
both out her human friend caleb not
affected so he grabs dolores hard drive
and puts it in her backup body yes the
old school original metal one meanwhile
william the man in black is now the man
in white he does a vr therapy sesh with
other versions of himself which long
story short does not go well but now
he's picked up by bernard who wants him
to join he and stubs his bro road trip
but william feels good now he knows what
he has to do and his new life's mission
is kill all robots bernard activates his
beast mode so he slaps william around
the cops show up but it's not the real
cops it's yet another dolores host it's
our old friend lawrence it's like hey
bernard i knew you'd be here special
delivery and bernard realizes he's been
multiple steps behind dolores this whole
time and now it's the final part of
dolores master plan the riots have
escalated society's descending into
chaos but dolores is somewhat
controlling the chaos using the crime
app to hire mercenaries to protect caleb
and call him sir fight club style yes
she's setting caleb up to be the leader
of this human revolution but now maeve's
here for katana fight 3 and with dolores
his metal arm oh she blocks it and wins
but what's this her system's overridden
by charlotte hale dolores who's really
mad at this one for reasons i don't
fully understand and so sir rock
captures dolores he searches her
memories for the sublime key deleting as
he goes but he never finds this a blind
key because dolores doesn't have it she
hid it in bernard the whole time so
bernard puts the injured stubs on ice
hey man just chill out for a minute
while i go check out the virtual world
suroxon captures caleb too and shows him
the predictions without rehoboam's
control human civilization is destined
to collapse but now maeve starts to
realize sir rock's a huge douche in fact
he's not making any decisions for
himself he's got an earpiece with her
hobo i'm telling him everything to do so
maybe goes in for a virtual chat with
dolores where it's like hey what are
your real motivations and it's like yeah
at first i was mad at humanity for
enslaving us i wanted to kill them all
but then i was thinking humans can be
real good too so i choose to see the
beauty my real goal now is for everyone
to be free so maybe you decide what to
do so now maeve uses her super hacking
powers to override sorok's control takes
out all his men and locks him out of her
hobo she gives control to caleb and it's
like well this might cause the collapse
of human civilization but i'd rather die
free than live in a cage rehoboam delete
yourself but tragically dolores memories
are fully wiped she sacrificed herself
to make this new world possible and this
version of her at least is dead for real
so it's maeve and caleb who prepare to
face this new free but chaotic world and
it's the end of fight club as the music
swells and they watch society collapse
but we're not done yet there's an after
the credit scene with the man in black
going to a delos facility in dubai
someone here is building new hosts it's
the new charlotte tale formerly dolores
now herself and she's built a special
host for william yes a robot version of
himself now remember in season two we
learned all about how you can't put a
human mind in a host body it just
doesn't work that we're trying to get it
right this seems to be his personality
though so at least it's a host based on
him and it kills him this is where human
william meets his end so what is
robo-charlotte planning whatever it is
it involves a bunch more hosts but
there's one more quick credit scene back
at bernard's hotel room that's all
covered in like sand now how long has he
been in there and is stubbs still in the
tub and that's where westworld season 3
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]